report joining us now here with reaction
Fox News contributor lieutenant colonel
in the Army Reserves tulsey Gabbert
former Democrat um when you hear these
massive numbers of people com coming
into our country and Joe is letting them
in from Syria Iran uh Russia China and
and China is buying up thousands of
Acres of Farmland thousands of Acres of
Ranch Land uh thousands of Acres near
military installations and you look at
Joe Biden's policies On the Border
giving up energy Security Law and Order
you see this chaos abroad tulsy what has
happened to the party you once called
home is there any of this that you agree
with because I don't think you do no
this is one of the main reason Sean that
I left the Democrat Party it is clear
and it has been for some time that they
don't care about the safety security or
freedom of the American people and they
have become apologists for these
islamist jihadists and Shauna got it
tell you for those like me the many
Americans like me who enlisted in the
military because of the 9/11 jihadist
terrorist attack on us this is
incredibly offensive you know i' I've
deployed three times to war zones in in
the Middle East and in Africa I know how
serious this threat of islamist jihadism
is the Democrat Elite they don't care
they don't care they instead they leave
our borders wide open which we know are
being exploited by these islamist
terrorists and they redirect our
security infrastructure our assets our
Intel assets not towards focusing on
these Terror threats that are coming
through our borders and elsewhere
they're focusing them on fellow
Americans they're focusing them on
people who they have deemed as domestic
terrorism threats or or extremists also
known as people who are supporters of
President Donald Trump or conservatives
uh and and I want to point out really uh
Sarah mentioned this but most
importantly we know that Iran has
sleeper terrorist cells here in America
and unlike uh the uh uh the al-Qaeda
these terrorist sleeper cells have the
access and capability and may have
already brought in nuclear material into
this country waiting to be activated and
if us could launch an attack here right
here at home that would make 911 uh look
small in comparison so the the graveness
of the threats that we face right now
Sean because of the failures of this
Administration the Democrat Elite
because they do not care about us
or our security this is what we're
facing I think especially with the UN
Jennifer Griffin reporting that the next
chair of the Human Rights Commission at
the uh Human Rights Council that the
un's going to be Iran yeah we fund most
of that organization the wef the wh with
Corona virus why are we a part of these
these globalist organizations number one
and number two what should America's
role be if Turkey if Iran Hezbollah
Hamas the hooes uh Syria are all after
one country what should we what should
America's role be we only have about a
minute well I I want to make the most of
this time Sean you're right the the
leaders of our country are not putting
the best interest the security interest
of the American people first the example
you cited earlier about turkey's erdogan
citing Hamas as being Freedom Fighters
well erdan himself is part of the Muslim
Brotherhood erdogan himself is a
supporter of Isis and Al-Qaeda erdan
himself has murdered our he should have
been kicked out a long time ago but
American leaders don't have the courage
to do what is necessary that's the
problem you know what this is what the
world looks like when America abdicates
its role as the world leader tulsy
Gabbert thank you very much hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it any where
else